Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start to shake.
I'm a cybernetic organism.
Hello,
this is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss show.
This is a special edition.
It is brought to you sponsor free and I would like to ask a favor in exchange,
ah,
but we're going to get to that in a second.
The first thing is a description of this episode.
This episode is actually a presentation by yours truly that I wanted to share
because I get asked all the time,
how did you build your network?
And if you look at the say guest list from this podcast or people that I invest
alongside,
it seems like a very impressive list and I'm impressed by a lot of these people,
but it was built in a very strategic,
a very methodical way and that doesn't mean it has to be artificial and not
looking at these friends as transactions.
These are relationships that I value,
but there is a right and a wrong way to network.
And in fact,
I think the best way to build a world class network is to spend very little time
networking per se,
collecting business cards and whatnot.
So this presentation really encapsulates my approach and what I've done,
uh,
particularly since about 2007 and I gave this presentation at south by
southwest,
which is a huge conference.
It started off with music than the interactive technology portion exploded.
And don't worry about the slides,
the visuals in each case,
if I bring up a slide,
I explain it via voice.
So you really don't need the visuals.
I was able to experience a tipping point for the four hour work week when I gave
my first presentation at south by southwest,
and I won't go into all the story because I do it in the presentation,
but it really triggered everything that came after it.
So it was a game changer,
a life changer for me.
So what did I do exactly at south by southwest that helped it become it the most
surprising self-help hit of the decade?
And quote according to Menstrual,
how did that happen?
And in the session I talk about exactly what I did that led to a higher
likelihood of that type of black swan event and the positive.
So I talk about biohacks for surviving and optimizing the booze marathon or
sleep deprivation,
which is inherent to events like this,
whether it's south by southwest Ted,
uh,
any number of other events that are multi day.
This is an important point and a very important subject to master the top
mistakes that I think 90% of attendees make,
how to pick your sessions,
parties,
et Cetera,
to make the most of all the madness,
how to interact with a listers or not.
And this is a very,
very important subject that I delve into and how to set yourself apart,
enjoy the ride and come away from the whole thing.
Because it is,
it is my opinion that if you choose one event properly and you build a network,
they're in the right way and a methodical way that really focuses on sort of
long term mutual relationships as opposed to transactions.
And a lot of the advice I think is counterintuitive or non obvious,
but it's very specific,
uh,
that you never have to network again ever.
And once you set that ball in motion,
it's like a snowball going down a hill.
And before you know it,
you have this unstoppable Goliath of inertia that can carry you forward four
years and in fact,
decades.
And that is what happened for me.
It's south by southwest and two,
that's seven.
And I want to explain exactly how that happened,
which is what the session will go into.
And the favor that I would love to ask you guys is I would love to try to
minimize sponsorships if possible,
because I only take sponsorships from companies whose products I use and have
vetted and so on.
Uh,
at the very least.
So I don't want to take a lot of sponsors.
I want to really limit it to that subset.
Um,
but the way that I can do that is by having you do something like subscribed to
my newsletter.
So for instance,
five bullet Fridays,
if you haven't been receiving these every Friday,
I send out a very short email of five bullets,
a containing the coolest things that I have found or been playing with that
week,
which could include favorite articles that I've shared with friends.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets that I've dug up somehow through experts and
purchased and played with all sorts of randomness,
but a lot of awesome stuff that you can use immediately.
And it's a very,
very short,
hence five bullet email.
So to check that out,
it's free and you can sign up very easily.
Tried out for a week,
see what you
think@fourhourworkweekdotcomforwardslashfridaysallspelledoutfourhourworkweek.com
forward slash Fridays so if you would like me to cut back on sponsors,
then please go sign up.
It would mean a lot to me and I think you will love it if you go on Twitter and
just look at Hashtag five the number five,
five bullet Fridays.
You will see a lot of people are excited about this.
That is it.
So without further ado or volume peaking,
I hope you enjoy this presentation on exactly how I built my network,
which is one of the most common questions that I get.
So enjoy it.
Please let me know your feedback.
I am at t Ferris TFE are our ISS on Twitter and thank you for listening.
Hey guys,
I'm flanked by dignitaries.
I used to have a rat tail.
How did I get invited to this party?
Well thank you all for coming.
I feel like a huge debt of gratitude to south by southwest because in 2007 prior
to that the four hour work week had been turned down by 26 publishers violently
in many cases and then at south by that year was the tipping point for the four
hour work week,
went on to hit the New York Times,
stayed there for almost four years on broken millions of copies,
30 plus languages later.
Here I am presenting kind of crazy and I've been back basically every year
since.
So I feel like I have a playbook,
a couple of tips,
tactics that hopefully you can use over the next few days to get the most out of
this event because I really feel like if you do south by properly,
once you never have to network ever again.
You don't have to Schmooze,
you can just coast and write it out.
So I'll try to give you a quite a bit of actionable information.
The subject matter of the previous presenter and the one after me,
far more important,
but I guarantee probably more profanity and crassness in this one said this
particular slide is me at burning man in 2008 after being thrilled with what
happened at south by,
I have very little recollection of this particular incidence and I suspect that
may be true for many of you over the next few days.
So let's start with Avocados.
No,
not Avocados.
We're going to talk about booze and specifically how you can mitigate the damage
that you're going to inflict on yourselves over the next few days.
And I'm not going to necessarily stop you from getting drunk.
I think that's part of the fun of being here.
I'm not going to stop you from getting dragged out of a club yelling.
Do you know who I am?
You can do that too,
but I want to help minimize the hangovers and the missing of sessions,
the missing of days here because that's a real travesty.
So a couple of recommendations.
If you've ever time traveled on alcohol,
what I mean by that is you're at a club,
then suddenly you're at Denny's eating moons over my Hammy and you're like,
how did I get here?
You've experienced a lack of vasopressin.
Vasopressin is a hormone that is associated with short term memory and ethanol.
The booze inhibits its release.
All right?
So you can compensate for that by let's say inhaling desmopressin which is a
synthetic version.
Don't do that.
I don't recommend that.
Uh,
but you can,
I'll retain more water.
Or why is this key?
Because it's also an antidiuretic hormone.
The reason you piss like a race horse is also related to this facet precedents.
And the reason you feel so hung over is because you've been dehydrated for a
long period of time.
So a very easy way to get around this,
especially in Austin,
is to have a bunch of guacamole before you go out.
Have some Avocados,
has more potassium than bananas.
Also a bunch of things that counter inflammation.
Okay?
So super simple.
Put a bunch of salt on it.
If you want to be indulgent,
you can put some balsamic vinegar in the middle as well,
which will lower your glycemic response to the pizza that you have.
Five pieces of when you're drunk later.
Uh,
it actually has a tremendous effect.
Have one glass of water for every alcoholic beverage you have.
Another way that you can mitigate the damage is to have clean drinks.
What would be an example of a clean drink?
Well,
if you want to get as drunk as possible with the least amount of effort and the
least hanging over,
you could have something called the nor cal Margarita in nor cal Margarita
popularized by a guy named Rob Wolf in the Paleo community is quite simply say
two shots of high great Tequila.
Reposado is a good choice mixed with a bunch of club soda and as much Lyme as
you can tolerate,
lemon will also work just,
it doesn't taste quite as good.
The club soda will allow you to absorb it very,
very quickly so you can be a cheap date.
And the the lime,
we'll also just like the vinegar,
inhibit your glycaemic response to food later.
So if you end up bingeing,
you won't have a carbon insulin coma the next day.
All right.
The last tip related to boost,
because I think this is such a key,
a key subject to master while you're here is activated charcoal or carbon.
So if you want to again,
minimize some of the damage you could go,
try to find that probably late for a lot of you to try to do that.
Burnt toast.
Okay.
Eat some burnt toast before you go out.
Uh,
if that doesn't sound appealing,
you can scrape off the burnt bits into yogurt and eat that,
which has actually been done in studies looking at trying to,
uh,
alleviate overdose of Acetaminophen so it can work.
Surprisingly enough.
Burnt toast,
Avocados,
Norco,
Margarita.
There you go.
All right.
Who is this person and why is she very,
very important?
So this woman,
lovely,
lovely woman is named Miriam.
And I met Marianne when I went to ces for the first time,
the consumer electronic show.
I'd never made it to the trade show.
And this is highly relevant to south by southwest.
I instead went to a sponsored lounge,
was the Seagate blog house,
h a u s and it was where they gave bloggers at the time.
That was social media,
basically gave bloggers free booze,
power outlets,
a place to rest and do work.
And I just went there and I hung out all day for several days and I had a
laptop.
So I was able to do work and I struck up casual conversations with people.
Hey,
what's the most interesting session you've seen so far?
Any cool products you've bumped into?
Didn't pitch anyone.
I got to spend time with Miriam because she was checking people in and we just
very casually had got into long conversations about where we were from,
et cetera.
Now the,
the big dog at the time,
and he's still very influential,
is Robert Scoble.
So he was in the blog house.
Everyone was crowded around him,
dozens of people vying for his attention.
And I knew I didn't stand a chance.
I didn't have a honed pitch for him.
I didn't even try.
And that's generally what I recommend.
Now.
It turned out that Miriam is Robert's wife and Marian said,
oh yeah,
you should totally hang out with Robert.
Like here,
just like shoot me,
shoot me a text or send me an email and we'll just meet up when you're back in
the bay area.
Fantastic.
And so,
uh,
Robert ends up getting a copy of the book.
He sends out a short mention in a blog post.
It takes the book to top 10 on Amazon for several days compared to morning
television.
At the time,
which would only take it to say top 50 for several hours.
That all came about because I follow these rules.
Don't dismiss people,
don't be a dick and don't rush.
Those are the three core tenants of success at an event like south by southwest.
Don't dismiss people.
You should behave here like everyone you interact with has the potential.
I can't wait to see the drawing for this.
Everyone has the potential to get you a cover story in the New York Times
because many of them do and it's just a good way to behave.
All right,
but you should behave like everyone here has a potential to get you a cover
story at the New York Times.
Uh,
don't be a dick.
Pretty self explanatory.
But let me give a couple of examples of all three so don't dismiss people.
I already gave you one.
I'll give you another one.
Specific to south by southwest.
I was going to a few movie screenings.
I went to one called big rig,
pretty cool movie and I was standing in line and the guy in front of me,
older gentleman had huge forearms.
And this is the kind of thing I noticed and I was like,
dude,
what is up with the forearms?
And we started talking.
Turns out he's a rock climber.
We talked,
we talked,
we talked about nothing business related whatsoever.
It turned out to be Morgan Spurlock's brother Morgan Spurlock showed up.
Maybe 10 minutes later.
We sat right next to each other,
the movie.
And then a few years later I ended up collaborating with him and he profiled me
for a day in the life.
Okay.
So again,
treat everyone like they're important because they are,
uh,
don't dismiss people.
I'll give you the converse example.
Last year I was here with my girlfriend at the time and had dozens of people
basically face Paul,
my girlfriend,
to push her out of the way to try to talk to me.
Not good politics.
Uh,
don't be a dick.
Again.
Pretty explanatory.
Self explanatory.
Not Limited to men by the way.
Um,
I've seen a couple of instances where,
for instance,
a friend was speaking to a female attendee and she asked if she could see the
apps on his home screen.
And he did this,
she grabbed the phone,
turned around,
and then sent a text to her number from his phone so she would have his phone
number.
Don't do that.
Don't rush.
This is the most important because it turns otherwise good,
reasonable,
wonderful people into those who do the the aforementioned too.
Don't rush play the long game.
All right,
and the mission that I would like to offer to all of you,
the job should you accept it,
is to realize that at south by southwest,
there are hundreds of people who could change your life completely.
Who could satisfy all of your wildest dreams financially,
reputationally,
phantasmagoric Lee,
I have no idea they can really make magic happen for you.
And your job should be to try to have a deep human connection with one of those
people before you leave.
That's it.
It makes south by southwest.
Very,
very manageable.
Uh,
an example of rushing,
and this has happened to be perhaps half a dozen times here at south by,
is the urinal encounter.
What is the urinal encounter?
It's when I'm trying to have my moment of Zen.
I'm at a urinal and I'm like,
ah,
deep breath,
and I'm thinking of the penguin in the caves chilling out.
I'm like,
okay,
I'm getting ready to go back into the melee in some startup founder will come
running up to me and skid to a stop.
He was like sweating cause he's nervous and starts like panting on the back of
my neck,
giving me a bitch.
If you want to make any human male that I'm aware of,
really uncomfortable.
Wait until they're staring at a wall holding their penis and come up and breathe
on the back of their neck.
Don't rush.
It.
Makes good people do bad things.
I promised to crass.
Alright,
next read bio's not sessions.
So how do you choose among all of the sessions?
You probably have some big fat book.
Then you're like,
oh my God,
how am I possibly going to tackle any of this?
Number one,
read the bio is not the sessions.
The session titles may not tell you the whole story.
Look for interesting people,
not titles of sessions.
And secondly,
don't just look at the people on the panel.
Look at the moderators.
And so what I did my first time to south by southwest is I would go to a panel,
I would listen to these amazing people on the,
on a given panel,
and then I would go up not to the A-listers on the panel.
Afterwards,
I would go up to the moderator,
many of whom are equally impressive in their own right now.
I would go to the moderator who is usually not nearly as mobbed,
and I would give them a quick explanation.
That's a,
Hey,
this is my first time at south by,
I don't know anyone,
Kinda lost,
just finished my first book.
It's about a,
B and c.
Uh,
personally I'm interested in at the time as a Brazilian Jujitsu,
this,
this and this.
Is there anyone here you think I might really hit it off with anyone you think I
should talk to?
I'm pretty good at this and this.
And they'd be like,
yeah,
sure,
I think a,
yeah,
you should talk to this person and this person.
And I just repeated that line of questioning over and over and over again.
And that's how I met many of the people who led to the tipping point for the
book and when I went up to those people who were referred,
by the way,
I don't say so and so said,
we should really meet.
Don't,
don't oversell it.
Just say,
I went up to them.
I asked them this,
they said this,
I figured what the hell,
maybe we'd hit it off.
Can I buy you a drink?
It's a very methodical way to go about tackling this delusion of sessions.
Next one.
Don't make an impression.
Leave a memento,
and I did a lot of research online,
pinged my audience on Facebook,
Twitter,
asked for questions.
One of them was,
how do I make a positive first impression?
Your job at south by southwest is to not make a bad impression,
right?
Because if all you're doing is trying to sell someone,
there are many different ways to do it.
Aside from coming to south by southwest,
what I would recommend,
especially in an instance where you're trying to reach,
say an a lister,
right?
Somebody who's getting mobbed and pitched all day long like an Anthony Bordain
or whoever it might be.
Don't try to give the pitch in person,
give them a folded up piece of paper with a page that you've painstakingly
crafted.
That is the perfect pitch.
Include your phone number.
You'd be surprised how many VIP folks like to call via Skype to have a
conversation as opposed to send you their personal email.
For instance,
don't make an impression.
Leave a memento.
Just say,
Hey,
I realize you're super busy.
You've got this long line of people,
you're under a lot of pressure.
I've thought about this.
I think this will be of great interest to you and just give them a teaser,
right?
Like if you have an impressive number of stat,
a client who's using it,
something like that.
Here you go.
I hope you have a great south by read it when you're on the toilet or have an
extra five minutes on the plane.
Thanks so much and you leave it at that.
That also shows you that you know how to play the game.
You know how busy they are.
You know,
the stress of the dealing with and immediately that will separate you from
everyone else as opposed to getting up and just micro machining through a pitch.
They won't remember even if they have spectacular memory.
Okay,
ignorance is bliss be the idiot.
I don't have to try very hard for this one.
So the key here,
and this is mostly a problem with men in my experience or boys or guys,
anything in between,
is we try to impress people.
So we stroll up and we're like,
well that's a good point.
You know what's even better point.
Or someone says something and you're like,
you know what,
that reminds me of this story.
That one ups your story.
Don't do that.
Uh,
and in fact you should do the opposite.
So one of the experiences that I had and challenges that many of you will have
is how do you get into a group conversation?
How do you interrupt people?
So my rules for that are,
number one,
if it's two people who are deep in conversation,
don't interrupt.
Okay?
Remember,
don't rush play the long game.
If it's two people just don't interrupt.
Wait if fits more people,
three,
four,
et Cetera,
you can saunter up and do what I did in 2007 which was say,
hey guys,
do you mind if I join?
You just eavesdrop.
It's my first time here.
I don't know anybody.
I'll buy you guys a round of drinks.
It's usually a place where he can get free drinks.
So it works out really easily and they're like a,
yeah,
okay,
sure.
Now the reason you don't just walk up and say like,
hey guys,
I'm just going to eaves drop is even though they're never going to say no,
at least you asked.
Be Polite.
All right.
So then they'd be like,
oh,
whatever man.
So I'd hang out and typically there'd be a lot of engineers.
I'm not a coder,
not an engineer.
And if someone said something that I was genuinely interested in clarifying,
so they'd be like,
well we did Dah,
Dah,
Dah.
And of course we ended up with ruby on rails and I'd say,
you know,
I'm really sorry to interrupt,
but I'm deep in the ignorance pool here.
Why was ruby on rails the obvious choice?
I don't know what it is,
but why was it such an obvious advantage?
And that will oftentimes spark a debate,
a debate among the people in that group.
And so every once in a while you throw out one of these questions again being
the idiot,
which is what good NPR host also do by the way.
And eventually someone will say,
Oh wait,
who the hell are you again?
Like what's your story?
And then you give them the shortest answer possible.
Do not launch into a really rushed long ass pitch.
So I would say,
well,
you know,
it's,
it's my first time here and I just finished my first book.
And the publishers basically controlling everything except for digital.
So I'm here to try to figure it out.
Pause.
Then you wait to see who asks if they do,
what's it about?
Great.
And then you say,
well,
it's about this,
this and this.
But I think most people here probably find this interesting.
And you see who digs deeper.
All right.
You'll see the logic to this in a second.
So let's just say you have a group of six people.
There's one person who has expressed extreme interest by digging and digging.
In the case of the four hour work week,
maybe they're interested in world travel,
virtual assistants,
that type of thing.
Then at the very end,
you know,
we'd bounce around and talk about all sorts of subjects and that's the,
uh,
zero pressure.
I would never expect you to write about it or do anything like that,
but I have a bunch of promotional copies from the publisher.
I could very easily just tab the 15 to 20 pages that I think you would find most
interesting based on what we just talked about.
And I can mail it to you and you know,
you can use it as a doorstop if you want.
And because I'd already honed down to the point where I knew who was interested,
I would say probably 90% of those folks said,
yes,
we're enthusiastic about it.
And then at least half of them ended up promoting it in some way because they
loved it,
not because I asked them to do it.
Does that make sense?
And if you say no strings attached,
do not fucking followup and bugged the shit out of them.
It's a great way to get a huge amount of negative backlash.
Don't do it and we'll come back to that.
But I tend to do very little followup except for something people have asked for
because people get enough email as it is.
Don't be a traffic bigot.
What does this mean?
This means that you may be,
if you have something to promote,
if you have a service websites,
start up book,
album,
whatever it might be,
movie,
you might be tempted to go straight for the person who has the biggest
megaphone,
the biggest site,
the most Twitter followers.
And the,
the problem with that is that you are going to be one of a thousand people who
pitch this person while they're here.
It 99.9% of the time,
it won't work.
You can try.
There's no harm in doing it tactfully.
It usually won't work.
What I did in 2007 and there were blog rolls at the time.
Do you remember those?
Uh,
is I tried to figure out,
and you can ask people right upfront,
moderators are good people to ask as well.
Who Do these people view as a thought leader?
Okay,
so you have this group of 10 traffic leaders.
Who Do they read?
Who are the niche folks that they read,
who were very influential,
who are the thought leaders?
And then you approached the thought leaders,
invite them out to a drink and you do the same thing that I just described and
be very,
very candid.
Basically do like the puss in boots,
you know,
holding the hat with the big eyes.
And uh,
and it's amazing what miracles can come of that because if you get covered by
one of those thought leaders in an interview,
for instance,
or anything like that,
or you send them an exclusive excerpt,
even though they have a small site,
you send them an exclusive excerpt of the book.
What happens?
They put it up and you're like,
AH,
who cares?
20,000 readers.
But guess who those 20,000 readers are?
Okay?
It's like being in front of 20,000 Ted Attendees.
Okay,
so don't be a traffic bigot.
And I would also say that don't necessarily focus on the people who you perceive
as the a listers are VIP.
Now try to find the pre VIP is,
does that make sense?
You're trying to find the up and comers.
So you ask again,
ask people who've been here a few times,
who are the best like up and coming hot designers,
you know the,
the,
the folks that are not very well known,
who should be well known or who are the hot dog,
the hot up and coming filmmakers who haven't had any press,
who were they?
Go meet those people.
And by the way,
if you did that just in safe film,
but you're actually based in tech,
you did that and film you met the best up and comers,
the best up and comers.
No one another.
The best VIP is an A-listers.
It's not industry specific.
Okay,
so don't be a traffic bigot.
They'll also have a much better time while you're here.
Questions for a listers.
So if you're like,
yeah,
yeah.
All right.
Ferris,
you know,
I'm still,
I'm still going to go for the gold.
I'm going to sprint up to,
you know,
Al Gore and give them a pitch.
Well,
how should you do it?
What are the questions?
What are the ice breakers for the a listers?
And the first rule as far as I'm concerned,
is ask if they have a second.
Don't just run up and pitch because a great pitch,
the perfect pitch at a bad time is a bad pitch.
It won't work.
And like I said at the beginning,
it's not about making a good impression.
That's about not making a bad impression.
If you make a bad impression,
they won't want to communicate with you later,
even if you correct things.
Okay.
So Mr Ms. May may bother you for 30 seconds.
Mr Ms x is now an okay time for one question.
If you say that,
don't ask three questions.
One question.
Uh,
now number two and number three here actually worked very well together.
You know,
Mr and Mrs x is now an okay time for one question.
Who on your team could I email about whatever you're interested in?
Okay.
They're not going to give you their personal email,
they're not going to give you their personal phone number usually,
and it's going to make them very uncomfortable to say no.
So realize that and ask about their team.
That will immediately put you in the pro category as opposed to the amateur
category.
And another thing,
if you're in a group,
let's just say at a book signing or something like that,
you have to realize,
even if they wanted to give you their personal email phone,
they can't say it out loud because 10 other people are gonna hear it.
So who on your team could email about blah?
And if they have entourage around them,
meaning let's just say you go to a book signing for,
fill in the blank,
right?
Michael Pollan,
and you see someone who's just kind of patiently waiting,
they're 10 feet away.
That is probably his publicist or his publisher or someone along those lines get
to know them.
They are probably the gateway to communication with Mr Pollen.
So you don't have to pitch directly.
And this relates to everything I've just said.
I'm not gonna spend a ton of time on it,
but you have to prove the messenger before the message you are the Messenger.
So for instance,
I had a startup come up to me while I was headed to this room today and uh,
I'm not going to mention the company name,
but they came up and the first thing they said was,
hey,
your assistant hasn't replied to my emails.
So I'm like,
what do you expect me to respond with?
How do you want me to respond to that?
Uh,
I get a lot of emails.
I don't know.
You know,
my assistant is pretty good.
I had a,
he ain't,
I dunno.
And then his buddy with them,
it's like,
yeah,
Mr Four hours,
like give me some four hour equip.
And I'm like,
if,
and then he gave me his business card and I'm like,
all right,
if I go to your site,
let's just say it's the most amazing sight I've ever seen in my life.
Am I going to want to be associated with that so that he can go up to somebody
else?
And be like,
yeah,
Ms. Dot.
Polin Mr Ferris works with us.
And that was like or no,
hell no.
That would destroy my reputation.
So you just screwed the pooch.
All right,
so be a good messenger before you deliver the message.
It doesn't matter how good the pitches,
if you fuck it up first
f bombs are coming.
How to pick people out of a crowd.
These are all related.
The questions that I get repeatedly,
how do you pick someone out in a crowd?
You're scanning the room.
You want to work the room.
Number one,
don't work the room.
Number two,
if you had to pick people out of the crowd,
I would say go for the most relaxed,
unrushed looking person.
Not necessarily the a listers surrounded by a huge Phalynx of people,
if that's the right word.
Because unless you just want to listen.
If you want to listen,
that's fine,
but you're not gonna get a lot of airtime.
Look for the most relaxed people in the room there.
They either have very,
very little going on or they've kind of already made it and they don't feel
rushed.
So hit or miss.
But if you have to pick people out of the crowd,
I would say go for the most relaxed unrushed looking person.
Alright.
Icebreakers in general and as a preface to this,
and I know you're reading the slide while I talk,
that's okay.
Uh,
the small talk is the big talk.
All right,
I'll repeat that.
The small talk is the big talk.
What that means is,
and that is an expression that has been said to me in many different words.
You know,
small talk is everything by friends of mine,
like a Ido Leffler who's a cofounder of yes to carrots.
They're distributed more than 30,000 locations.
And the point that he would make,
and the point that I would also make is that if you're just going to pitch
people,
you can probably do that in a more effective way by staying at home,
not coming to Austin and just sending out cold pitches,
working on your email skill here in person,
you have an opportunity to dig deeper and talk about other things.
That is how you become memorable.
That is how you have that one deep human connection that I was talking about.
So instead of asking what do you do,
and there are people who will ask that of you and you can be like,
Whoa,
shoot a lot of heroin or what about you?
That's a good way to
end it.
Or you can give it a really boring answer and like,
ah,
sometimes I'll just be like,
yeah,
I'm a freelance writer.
You know,
I was still trying to make it work.
And they're like,
ah,
they're already scanning for their next prey.
So instead of what do you do,
what do you ask?
And I understand why this is difficult because people are like,
ah,
I don't know.
And then they come up with something like if you could be a breakfast cereal,
what breakfast cereal would you be?
And people are like,
that's Kinda what the hell is happening.
So don't do that.
You can make it pretty natural.
So for instance,
if you ask,
oh,
so and so,
Hey,
nice to meet you,
where are you from?
And they say,
Oh,
I'm from New York City.
Are you from New York City originally?
Say No,
I'm from Cincinnati.
Well how do you get from head ended up going from Cincinnati and New York City?
You're going to get all the information you could possibly need for context.
Okay,
boom,
you've got it.
And you'll oftentimes have a very good personal story to go with it.
All right now if you don't want to do that or later on,
if you want to sort of expand a little bit,
you could ask,
you know,
what session are you most excited about?
What's been your favorite session so far?
If it's a few days from now,
for instance,
you know,
what are you most excited about these days?
And it's not that you can't talk about work,
but you can do that anywhere.
The any medium in person is a unique opportunity.
So optimize for meat space.
Take advantage of the fact you probably have some booze involved and you have a
chance to talk about the personal stuff.
How do escape slash pause conversations?
So,
you know,
what do you do if you get cornered by someone's selling timeshares?
Or what do you do if someone is just on meth and will not start talking about
their startup and they're just going and going and going?
What do you do?
Well,
I would say a few things and I,
and I put escape slash pause because I think pause is the better way to think
about it.
You could try to pull the bathroom maneuver.
People always try this,
uh,
and it can work and be like,
you know,
that's awesome.
So fascinating.
I really have to go to the bathroom.
I'll be right back.
The dangers of doing that,
number one,
if you don't come back,
you kind of look like a dick.
So violates the don't be a dick role.
Uh,
if you don't even go to the bathroom,
if you're like,
yes,
I need to go to the bathroom,
then you just walk 20 feet and then just start talking to someone.
They're going to be like,
picture at So-and-so.
What did Dick so don't do that.
Uh,
the easiest way to do it,
you don't have to make up.
So,
oh my God,
my house is on fire,
my wife is going,
I have to go.
You don't have to do that.
You can just say,
and this is what I do and I do this with people I find very,
very interesting.
Also,
if it's just like,
okay,
we've been talking for an hour in your head,
you're thinking this,
I just want to wander around a little bit.
Say that.
So you asked them,
hey,
you know,
James or whatever,
you know.
Hey James,
you're going to be here for the rest of the,
uh,
for the rest of south by,
are you gonna be here for a couple of days?
Yeah,
I'm going to be here for the next two days.
Cool.
Well,
do you have a card or something?
I'd love to connect,
but I just want to wander around.
Maybe take a little breather,
grab a cup,
coffee.
You're done.
That's great.
It's polite.
It's honest.
That's all you have to do.
Are you going to be here for the rest of south by?
Are you gonna be here for the next couple of days?
Cool.
Can I get your card?
Greatest?
Want to wander around?
Take a break,
hit the bathroom,
grab a cup of coffee,
but I'm sure I'll see you around.
Nobody's offended and you accomplish the purpose of pausing the conversation.
Next follow up.
All right,
so during the event,
after the event,
how do you follow up?
Uh,
first of all,
don't do anything to keep in touch.
It will just make enemies.
All right?
You don't need to paying busy people.
Just be like,
hey,
how's it going?
How are you doing?
You know,
I imagine that you are calling them at like 3:00 PM.
All right?
So you call them.
They're like,
as an investment banker running around,
Oh my God,
you're a startup.
You're like,
we need an underwriter.
So you call this busy and this isn't bagger.
At 3:00 PM,
you're like,
Hey John,
it's uh,
it's Tim from south by Zach,
uh,
Tim,
Tim Ferris.
Hey Doug,
how's it going today?
Don't do that.
It's just be like,
what the fuck?
I'm really busy.
Hey,
don't do that.
So follow up is a dish best served cold but I mean by this is most people are
going to walk out of south by pockets full of business cards,
big ideas,
people to follow up with paypal,
the Pang brains to pick.
Don't ever ask anybody if you can pick their brain over coffee by the way.
But that's a separate story.
So follow up.
Wait two weeks.
Okay,
wait two weeks.
Why two weeks?
Because if you do it now,
it's going to get lost in the avalanche of similar stuff.
If you do it right after south by,
it'll be even worse.
You're going to get lost in it.
Another hundred followup email.
So it takes people time to catch up from neglecting other things during south by
wait two weeks.
And then in terms of time,
I would do it on a Wednesday afternoon their time or a Friday afternoon.
Their time.
Sunday night also works pretty well.
So for responses from Max response rate and read rate,
those tend to be the times that I find most effective.
Play the long game,
play the long game.
All this means is you don't have to rush.
Why?
Because you just have to have one deep human connection with one person.
That's it.
If you can accomplish that and develop a longterm relationship,
you can potentially never have to network again.
I know that sounds like an exaggeration,
but if you look back at the people I spent the most time with in 2007
realistically you probably,
it'd be able to have a couple of these human interactions try to get out of
tech.
By the way,
don't do all tech.
If you look at the people I spent the most time with in 2007 but 90% of them,
this is 2007 what does that seven years ago,
my God,
there's still some of my closest friends to this day.
That is what you want because if you don't do that,
you play the short game.
You have to then do this very time consuming,
very energy consuming,
very likely to offend a transactional stuff every for the rest of your life.
Do you really want to do that?
No.
No you don't.
So play the long game guys.
That is it for my formal presentation.
So I am going to open it up to the rest of Twitter Q and.
A.
But I hope you all have a wonderful,
wonderful experience to south by southwest.
If you do it right,
it will change your life.
So again,
just in summary,
don't dismiss people,
don't be a dick and Dora rush play the long game.
Thank you.
Thanks so much Tim.
If you guys have specific questions that you want to ask,
if you want to Hashtag your tweet with ask Tim,
we will pull them up and he will answer all of your lovely questions,
concerns ponderings I and here is our first question.
I really should have worn my glasses for this.
I can read it.
All right,
so this is from Wendy Perry.
Uh,
can you guys read this is,
well maybe I don't have to read all of these but I will just for those who are
getting this on audio,
after I read the four hour work week,
years ago,
I took my family on a mini break once a month.
Can you have too many?
This is,
this is in reference to mini retirements and taking these sabbaticals.
So distributing retirement throughout life as opposed to
waiting until say 50,
60,
72,
uh,
to load it up at that point.
Uh,
I think that this is a deeply personal question.
So in terms of mini retirements,
I tried to take one to three months,
usually two to three months of these mini sabbaticals per year.
I think that if you use these mini retirements as a way of postponing other
important decisions,
and of course it could be too many.
So the,
if you look at your to do list and usually the most uncomfortable item is the
most important.
If you're using these trips to avoid that,
then I'd say it's too many.
All right.
Next is from Zachary Barker.
If you were launching a new company with only a thousand dollars to get started,
what would you start?
So we get a lot,
I get a lot of questions like this.
It's like,
um,
if you had no connections and no money,
how would you make $100,000 in the next quarter?
And what business would you start?
Uh,
this is a question of what I would say.
I'd spend the first $10 getting the 22 immutable laws of marketing and now to
figure out which market you're going after first and then design your product.
And specifically I would also read 1000 true fans by Kevin Kelly and identify
who your,
what the demographic and psychographic is of the thousand people you want to
have us die hard fans first and foremost.
Non Celebrities.
In my case with the four hour work week,
I knew that my first market,
not my entire market,
but my first market would be 25 to 40 year old tech savvy males in New York City
and San Francisco.
How do I reach those people?
How can I seem say ubiquitous by being on five websites when in fact I'm not
ubiquitous,
I'm just everywhere that they happened to look.
Okay.
That's where I would start.
But I can't say,
you know,
put all your money in bitcoin or something like that,
which I think,
uh,
it would be dangerous,
especially if you only have 1000 bucks.
So test often test small.
I think Facebook is a great place to thin slice,
but,
uh,
that would be my advice.
Do you meditate or do yoga?
Uh,
I do meditate.
I meditate almost every morning for ideally 20 minutes.
It's only something that I've done consistently for the last year or so.
All right.
Uh,
and uh,
I personally use TM,
transcendental meditation.
I find some of the gurus stuff a little woo.
I'm not for that,
but just the repetition of a sound I find very,
very effective as opposed to say concentrative meditation,
uh,
or,
other types of Vipassana also very,
very helpful.
Um,
I am not a,
I don't do a lot of yoga.
I become fascinated with acro yoga,
which is more like a Cirque de Solei strength performance than anything else.
But those are the two I meditate a lot more than I do yoga.
Uh,
Anthony Blattner,
how do you find the good events and parties instead of the overpacked events?
Uh,
good events and parties.
All right.
So I plan my sessions,
although there's room to improvise,
I let the parties pick me.
What that means is I choose the sessions,
I interact with people in the way that I described.
And then you just ask,
okay,
try to have some spontaneity and just wander around and get lost.
In terms of events,
if we're talking about conferences in general,
um,
this is going to sound haphazard,
but my policy has generally been go to at least one event per year,
which is the most expensive event you can afford to go to.
You're going to end up with a smaller crowd.
And I find that at least interesting to experiment with.
Uh,
but obviously you don't want to bet the farm on it.
next question from a littlest gator.
And I like that name.
If you've ever heard little baby alligators,
like a rare,
rare when they're calling their mother,
it's amazing.
I really want this guy to make that noise.
All right.
And now that you are a big deal,
what are your goals at South by southwest?
Um,
I don't think I'm a big deal compared to a lot of folks,
but my goal is to south by southwest.
Honestly,
I,
I was offered the opportunity to do how to rock south by southwest.
And I feel a huge debt of gratitude to south by,
I think it's one of the most incredible events out there.
And if you do it right,
it can be totally life changing.
So I don't have,
I don't have a new book,
I don't have a new thing to promote this time around.
It's really just to have fun,
eat some barbecue and hopefully allow you guys to do the same.
Next.
Mark Marshall or Michelle,
uh,
what thought leaders do you follow
or are there specific writers,
bloggers that I read?
Uh,
right now at this point in time,
uh,
there,
there's some very interesting folks out there.
I mean a Nasim Tala is one that comes to mind immediately.
But in terms of reading,
I'm trying to actually read really old ideas right now.
So trying to focus on books that had been around for a hundred plus years
whenever possible.
Uh,
because uh,
in a,
in an age of,
of Femora.
And is it a neo mania and float and obsession with the new,
the new,
the new.
I like ideas that have stood the test of time for awhile.
How do I stay focused?
I'm not convinced I am focused,
but meditation helps a lot.
Uh,
and really the purpose of that session in the morning,
I might just be thinking of like some guy cut me off in the salad line and
college that I want to like punch in the nose for 19 minutes of that.
But if I'm thinking of that and I'm like not productive and then I go back to
what I'm supposed to be doing just once,
that will translate to being able to do the same thing in your normal life.
So I think that's very,
very helpful.
In terms of books on meditation,
uh,
the first book by Tick Not Hun,
is very,
very good.
All right,
melody towel.
How do you deal with criticism?
You get for not replying to email right away?
You know what,
I'm going to,
I'm going to head,
I'm going to dodge this one just because I answered it at length in the four
hour workweek.
Um,
so I apologize guys,
but that's a long,
long answer so that,
that one we're going to save for the four hour work.
I'm sure it's on torrent somewhere if somebody wants to read it for free,
uh,
or her.
But Morielle question,
what part of your four hour work week do you personally find hardest to follow?
What I've found hardest and what I still find hardest to saying.
No.
You have to say no to a thousand things before you can say yes to the one big
thing that's going to change your life.
And I still find that difficult.
I think we all like people to like us and some people take it very personally
when you don't get back,
get back to them quickly.
Like this startup founder kind of accosted me outside.
It's like,
and I feel badly,
uh,
but at the same time I'm just like,
try to walk a mile in my shoes.
If you could just think about it,
because I used to take it personally too.
I'd send an email to a really busy person.
They would never respond to be like,
wow,
what a dick.
You have to try to imagine yourself in their shoes.
And the reality is they're getting thousands of email,
thousands of pitches.
I probably 90% of the interactions I have at south by southwest,
we'll be people pitching me.
So just imagine how that would feel and how tiring it would be before,
uh,
taking it personally.
But I still find saying no quite challenging.
Uh,
Ryan Bond Heart.
How do I want people to remember me?
Uh,
I would say I don't need people to remember me.
If they remember the ideas,
that would be fantastic.
Um,
most of which I've borrowed from other people or just collected.
But I would say that my goal is to be a world class teacher and to create people
who are better than I am.
So if I can create armies,
thousands,
tens of thousands,
millions of people who are worldclass learners and in turn can be worldclass
teachers then and better than I am.
Which is necessary,
then,
uh,
I think the world be a better place.
So hopefully that's something I can do.
John Adelai,
what tricks do you have for retaining info?
If it's factual,
declarative information,
facts and figures?
Uh,
there's a book written by a gentleman named Higbee,
I think it's called your memory and how to improve it,
but the last name is Higbee mnemonic devices as used by Cicero and for several
thousand years work really well.
Ed Cook,
c.
O.
K.
E also fascinating guy,
a worldclass memory competitor.
I interviewed on the podcast.
What's the next project book that I'm working on?
Well,
uh,
more details to come shortly,
but uh,
well okay,
I'll give you guys some,
some breaking news.
No one knows this.
I was able to negotiate back the rights for a TV show that I filmed sometime ago
and I will be digitally distributing the Tim Ferriss experiment to the,
well,
I would like to say the world,
there are some constraints geographically,
but I will be distributing it and making it available to as many people as
humanly possible in the next few months.
So that's,
that's very exciting for me.
Hopefully I can come back to south by next year and do something in the film
track and talk about these new avenues for distribution,
which I think are really exciting.
Uh,
homeless coder.
That's the grant.
Uh,
it's funny,
I saw a guy,
I saw a guy two days ago in San Francisco.
He was like slow motion karate,
chopping this tree.
And in my mind I was like either that guys high as balls on Lsd or he's coming
up with the next billion dollar idea.
It,
he's a coder.
It's gotta be one of the two homeless gutter.
You've advocated mini retirements and travel.
Where's the best place in the world besides Austin?
I,
you know,
it,
this is like what's the best pair of shoes in the world?
You,
you have to find a pair that fits.
And it's not the same for everybody.
Some people like those crazy like pointy witch of the west shoes.
I've seen a lot of guys in those.
Not My thing.
You know,
I'm,
I'm not like a flip flop guy.
Uh,
I love Japan.
I have a huge affinity for Japan.
I lived there for a year in high school.
That's,
that's the Argentine is a lot of fun too.
It's amazing how they can get anything done.
There's beautiful areas,
people,
a great wine,
great steak.
Japan is amazing because it is a place where you can be completely confused and
illiterate and lost and not be in danger.
So if you want to be a really,
really uncomfortable but not really in any particular danger,
Japan is a,
a great place to do it.
Uh,
Melanie curtain,
what are you most excited about for this year?
South by,
I'm most excited about eating a lot of animals.
Uh,
I don't,
I don't have a real agenda while I'm here.
There are a number of friends of mine who have moved to Austin because it is the
best place in the world.
Uh,
and I'd like to just reconnect with some of my friends,
many of whom I met in the,
actually two of them I'm meeting in the next three days.
I met for the first at south by in 2007 and they've continued to be to my best
friends.
So that's about it.
Uh,
this is from be cursed 77 on your podcast with Matt Mullenweg.
You guys spoke briefly about poly synchronous sleep.
Have you tried it?
Does it work?
Uh,
supply synchronous?
I've,
I've never heard it phrased that way.
Most people have heard if they have heard it,
um,
polyphasic sleep where you take instead of a single hour,
or I'm sorry,
a single block of eight hours,
you can break it down into fractions where you can get down to two,
two and a half hours of sleep.
If you do it,
take a 20 minute nap every few hours.
I have tried it and it can work.
And I still am a,
I'm a huge believer in naps,
huge,
huge believer in naps despite the fact that I have a lot of trouble with them,
a pro tip for naps that I've realized it's not about falling into,
it's not about falling asleep.
It's about laying down and closing your eyes and just blocking out some sensory
input.
So don't get stressed out if you can't fall asleep for 20 minutes and just lay
down and chill out.
Um,
I've tried it.
It works.
It's massively antisocial.
You can have no social calendar whatsoever.
So I don't typically follow it.
Luigi linguine though.
What's the most memorable thank you note that I've received?
Ooh,
that's a good question.
I've been very fortunate.
I've had a good,
a good tear over the last couple of years and uh,
there's,
there's a luck component.
There's a timing component.
Uh,
you know,
hopefully there's some kind of competency component.
But uh,
you know,
the first one that's coming to mind,
I've,
I've received a lot of really lovely thank you letters,
but the first one that comes to mind has nothing to do with the four hour work
week.
It's actually a collection of thank you notes from,
I think they were third graders or fourth graders from doing work with donors,
choose.org,
which is an educational nonprofit.
Uh,
I really love and spend a lot of time with them on their advisory board.
And I got this collection of thank you notes for supplying some basic materials
like books or pens or pencils.
So that's the first one that comes to mind is just these,
these hand,
you know,
crack a lot of,
I'm not a parent yet,
so I don't have the,
uh,
you know,
the like poorly drawn brontosaurus to stick on my refrigerator and I got,
30 hand drawn and letters from these kids,
which was just awesome.
A GD m l are you recording a podcast while here at south by if yes.
With whom?
I don't have any plans to record here at south by,
I might,
uh,
who knows.
I might,
they'll do a man on the street,
walk around,
see how many drunk people I can get to say incriminating things.
I Dunno,
but no,
no plans right now.
Uh,
what animal best describes you?
Edwin Lee.
Also a good question.
This is a good one.
Um,
Alexis Ohanian of y Combinator likes to ask people in job interviews,
what is your spirit animal,
uh,
which I think gets a pretty good answer.
Uh,
or causes some awkward as the very least a coyote,
I'd say.
I'd say a prankster joker.
It's we,
we go into that for a while,
but I'll just leave it.
I think coyote is pretty good one.
Jackie Bloom.
I have a nine to five job can for our work.
We actually transformed my life.
Hope not in a position to leave my regular job.
Uh,
I would say yes.
And the,
the reason I say that is that the four hour work week is a really a cult,
a portfolio of tools for maximizing your power output.
So there was somebody actually just on Twitter a couple of days ago,
if you look at my favorites,
if you look at my favorites on Twitter at t Ferris,
you can see tons and tons of real life case studies from the four hour workweek
for our body.
And one of them was,
you know,
it took me five months to negotiate it,
but I now have a room up,
a remote work agreement.
So he's in his current job,
same job,
getting paid the same amount,
but it has complete freedom of mobility.
That's a big deal.
And uh,
cause that,
that helps to reward performance over presence and at least a great thing.
So it's a,
it's not about getting to a four hour work week for everyone.
It's about maximizing your output and then making better decisions with more
options.
Andrew Berg,
uh,
what are the three to four best bodyweight exercises for business travelers?
Well,
uh,
I would say you can keep it really simple
pushups,
planks.
If you want to make planks harder,
you can put the soles of your feet against the wall so your feet are off the
ground and you have to press them back into the wall to make it work.
That's quite challenging.
Uh,
and a pull ups,
if you have access to pull ups,
I would say that if you do just that pistols,
if you can handle it.
But pistols are hard for a lot of people.
There's one legged squats,
uh,
otherwise,
just two tips.
If you train your abs and your grip,
you can keep the entire,
your entire body in really good shape.
Uh,
abs,
we were talking about planks.
Listen to my podcast with Pavel Tsatsouline for more details on that.
Get some hand.
Grippers as a,
as a dude,
I'm not sure was all the ladies here and wanting like thick,
calloused meat hooks,
but a gripper is grippers or are incredible travel with.
And you can also,
if you're really aggressive and want to go for it,
you can get a kayaking dry bag that people use to put their wallets and so on.
I phones inside to keep dry wall.
It turns out you can use a dry back to contain water also.
So you can roll up a dry bag,
travel with it,
fill it up with water,
sat in the bathtub and get it up to like 30,
40 pounds.
And you can just use that as a kettle bell or as a dumbbell.
So you can,
you can get around the space constraints.
Jesse Conover what's the best way to respond to,
do you have a business card when I don't have one?
What's this?
Ah,
no,
I I just say I'm sorry.
I'm really unprofessional.
I don't have business cards.
That's it.
I have no,
uh,
I think that does,
it does the job.
And then usually I say,
I'm sorry,
I don't have your business cards,
but you know,
I'll,
I'll shoot my info if you mean it.
If not,
then don't say that.
Uh,
all right,
next question.
Okay.
Eric Coleman.
What do you most entrepreneurs do wrong?
Okay.
What most entrepreneurs do are all,
uh,
I think they try to do what was most entrepreneurs
invest too much in their business before they test product market fit.
So do what I mentioned before and read the 22 immutable laws of marketing.
Read a thousand true fans by Kevin Kelly,
which is free and figure out exactly who your ideal customer is and who those
thousand people are,
where they're located,
what they read,
where they'd be on Facebook,
which pages they've probably liked,
and test your landing page.
Use something like unbounce or lead pages or something to test the offer before
you invest in a ton of inventory or a ton of software development.
And,
uh,
I think that's,
that's the right way to approach it.
Along the same lines as Luigi at Dell,
what's the most memorable Momento I've received?
Uh,
boy.
Okay.
Uh,
again,
it's just the first one that comes to mind.
Uh,
I was in Japan at one point filming a TV show where I was attempting to learn
Japanese horseback archery in a week.
A really dangerous turns out.
I don't recommend it.
You can,
you can find it online if you,
if you just search Japanese horseback archery and my name of all of the things.
Uh,
and the teacher there gave me a,
an a,
an out of prints,
tiny book on job with Ami,
which it's called in Japanese that he was featured in with an inscription from
the,
the foremost family who used to work with the shogunate teaching.
Uh,
Ya'll was not me.
And,
uh,
the,
sort of prodigy right now who's an incredible writer,
incredible archer has a jacket.
He didn't give me the jacket.
I would have loved the jacket,
but it said,
oh God.
Salata Yabu thought since 1157,
or something like that instead of 11,
since 11 something.
And I was like,
that is amazing.
I want that jacket.
I didn't get the jacket.
I got the book.
But that was enough.
All right.
Advice for introverts.
Uh,
advice for introverts is a take time.
Timeouts.
So I,
I can play the extrovert,
but I get exhausted at events.
I get exhausted and crowds,
I get exhausted at book signings.
I get really,
really drained.
I recharge my batteries by myself.
So if you need to take a break,
go outside,
chill out for 10 minutes and leaned against the wall,
like laid out on the park,
uh,
take time to recharge.
If you try to play the extrovert for too long,
you'll just get burned out and then the next day you won't even participate.
So drink a lot of water and recharge.
Josh,
Janssen,
what are some of the biggest lessons you've learned from starting my podcast?
Uh,
the podcast started as a lark.
It was really a commitment to do six episodes because I wanted to get better at
conversation and asking questions.
My favorite part of writing books is not actually the writing,
it's the research and it's worldclass experts and trying to deconstruct what
they do.
And I viewed the podcast as a way of practicing that and getting much better at
it.
And I'd had some wonderful experiences being interviewed on say,
Joe Rogan's podcast or Mark Marin.
And I wanted to see if I enjoyed being the host.
Uh,
so I would say first and foremost,
what I've learned is that,
uh,
it's not enough to have the right question,
to have the right answers.
You need to have the right questions so you can get,
you can get a great answer to the wrong question and it ends up meaning very
little.
But if you have,
if you have a portfolio of really good questions,
man,
you can do just about anything.
And,
uh,
that's number one.
Number two is ask simple follow on questions.
So someone says,
well,
I did this,
this,
why did you choose to do that?
What did you learn from that?
You know,
what did you learn from that that you haven't talked about before?
Uh,
these,
these follow up questions are often where the gems really come out.
All right,
next question.
Gabby did.
Leon,
what are some tips for executing on all the great ideas gathered at I a Iowa?
Oh,
interactive.
What was I,
I'm not sure.
Uh,
once we returned home,
I'm guessing that is from the conference.
Uh,
you don't want to execute on all the great ideas.
It's way,
way,
way too much.
So I would look at your ideas,
the potential collaborations and all of that and ask yourself which one of
these,
if,
if executed,
will make all of the others irrelevant or easier and then focus on that one.
So find the lead domino and focus on that.
I think we'll take one more question and then direct everyone to the signing.
Sure.
All right.
Next one is gender,
which for Borsky.
Let's do it.
Let's do one more question after this cause I don't think I have a good answer
for this.
Is there any particular session that south by that you want to attend?
At least one.
Um,
I wasn't able to get my badge yet,
so I haven't had a chance to get the book with the sessions.
Uh,
let's do one more.
Hmm.
This is a good one.
Alex.
Why cough?
What questions do you use for reflection and why?
So reflection,
meditation,
I view those as the same thing.
Uh,
I will journal in the mornings quite often and,
uh,
whenever I'd say every four to eight weeks at longest,
I will wake up in the morning and I will do an 80,
20 inventory of my emotional states.
So what does that mean?
That means that I'll sit down before checking email during any of that,
checking my phone and I will ask the question,
you know,
water 20% of the activities and relationships that are producing 80% of my
positive emotional states.
And then what are the 20% of activities and people who are creating 80% of the
negative emotional states,
the overwhelm,
that guilt and so on and uh,
put together a to do list and,
and not to do list accordingly.
Specifically the not do list the things to cut
out.
So those are,
that is the,
uh,
the set of questions that I find most valuable.
Good question and good answer.
Well,
cool.
Thanks again Tim and thanks everyone here for joining us.
Everybody have a great soundbite.
They
guys,
this is Tim again.
Just a few more things before you take off.
Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short email from me every Friday that provides a
little morsel of fun before the weekend and five bullet Friday is a very short
email where I share the coolest things I've found or that I've been pondering
over the week.
That could include favorite new albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the other world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance.
And it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness before you head off for the weekend.
So if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to a four hour work week,
[inaudible] dot com that's four hour work,
week.com all spelled out and just drop in your email and you will get the very
next one.
And if you sign up,
I hope you enjoy it.
And until next time,
thank you for listening.
Yeah.
Okay.